The joe rogan experience.
Trevor,
welcome buddy.
How's it going man?
Good man.
When we were,
I sometimes when people sit down and you know,
you just start talking and you're like,
shit,
Shit,
stop talking.
We've got to record Trevor's a paleontologist and explained to me the job site
thing.
Like when someone's digging you have to,
you they need a paleontologist onsite in certain places.
Uh,
well it all depends on really where you are.
So here in the state of California,
we have a,
uh,
a law called sequel.
It was started in 1970 and that main dates mandates that any archeological or
paleontological stuff.
So like dead bodies of,
of,
you know,
early Californians are glass where all the way up to a woolly mammoth bones are
not willy mammoth,
mammoth bones,
saber tooth cats,
stuff like that.
Or even older has to be mitigated.
They have to be protected.
So my job right now,
I work work for a company called SWCA environmental consultants.
We go out and we make sure that the glassware and the fossils and the bones and
all that that get found by 40 ton excavation machines when they're building new
hotels in downtown.
Wow.
So yeah,
I'm standing next to things that could very easily kill you.
So when they do that,
how do they keep from fucking something up?
Like what are,
when they're digging in,
is it just dumb luck that you know,
they,
they fuck stuff up.
That's how we find it.
Cause we don't have x Ray Vision.
I can't like look into the ground and go,
hey,
there's a whale there.
Um,
so the bulldozers going by the excavators scooping stuff up and then scrambling
to check.
Yeah,
it,
it digs this big hole,
dumps it over.
I'm looking in the hole and I'm looking over at the spoil pile where they're
mounting everything up and trying to hop back and forth.
And all of a sudden you hear this sickening crunch and you're like,
oh,
you wave everybody off and there's like this bone sticking out and you sweep it
away.
I'm like,
Oh crap.
It's a mammoth.
Okay.
And then I shut the shut.
I shut the job site down to they get mad at you?
Oh yes.
Really?
Yeah.
What's like the biggest thing you've found and how pissed where they?
Um,
I can't say exactly where,
but somewhere here in Los Angeles,
uh,
I was part of a team.
So the job site I was working on,
they found a whale,
a whale,
a fossil whale of 5 million year old whale.
Whoa.
Where there's no water right now.
Holy Shit.
Think like downtown La Whale.
Wow.
That's why,
how long?
5 million years old.
About 5 million years old.
Holy Fuck.
We were finding shark's teeth and stuff like that,
hanging around.
Um,
and the,
the owner of the company was a,
the,
the owner of the,
uh,
the uh,
construction company.
The forgot what their name is,
a supervisor.
I'm the general contractor.
Uh,
he's like,
Oh,
you're just finding teeth.
I'm like,
well,
you know where you find really big shark teeth?
You occasionally find their food and they ate whales and he's like,
Oh,
you won't about three weeks later up.
Yup.
Look,
Wale Rib cage.
Wow.
The whole rib cage.
So how big is that following year old whale?
The jackets?
About three quarters.
The size of this table.
A jacket?
Yeah.
Um,
sorry.
I'm like thrown out terms.
We wrap a fossils in plaster to protect it because we're taking the dirt out
with them so we can prep it later.
So I'm going to like take out hammers and chisels and about a month and try and
work all of the bones out of this big block of dirt.
So we wrap plastic around it.
We call it plaster jacket.
Oh.
So we put all that on there.
And so yeah,
it's about three quarters the size of this table.
I mean it's like 1920 ribs,
like three or four verts some other random bones.
We don't know what it is and what makes like some of it stay in the dirt and the
rest of it deteriorate.
Like what's the dumb luck?
Just dumb luck.
Absolutely dumb luck.
It's a,
we get a lot of,
uh,
you know,
paleontology.
It's still a young science.
It started in the 18 hundreds and England pretty much before that.
Yeah.
Before that was natural philosophy,
natural philosopher philosophy.
Like how so?
Uh,
like in the 1860s when Darwin released the origin of the species is big book on
evolution.
He was saying,
Oh,
you know,
we don't have that many things in the fossil record.
Cause Paleontology was still new.
Like three years later they found archaeopteryx that big,
that big lizard bird archaeopteryx early bird.
They found that and then everyone went nuts.
It's like,
oh crap,
look,
evolution fossils,
this is awesome.
So it was this huge uptick in,
in study and now it's one of the,
I mean Ross on friends was a paleontologist.
How many people do you know,
I saw Jurassic Park or 10,000 BC and all that paleontology we're kind of getting
into,
uh,
getting into its own swing again.
It's Kinda cool right now.
We're kind of cool right now.
We've got piercings were covered in tattoos were kind of,
we're cool.
Hipster.
You could,
you could easily be like a chef somewhere or a comic.
Well I've,
I've seen that.
I have a lot of visible tattoos.
I'm wearing jeans today,
but I'm like,
I've got them all over my legs too.
And they're all like science.
Either science or Geeky.
Oh,
cool.
And I've seen chefs with like spatulas carrots and minor,
minor like fossil sharp teeth and saber tooth cats.
Yeah.
What does that if turtle the toe and,
Oh,
it's a frog.
It's a horned lizard.
Yeah.
It's uh,
my favorite horn lizard.
It's a,
the regal horned lizard from the desert southwest.
I'm a nerd man.
I'm a total,
I'm world needs nerds.
Some important,
I love nerds.
Lego's,
transformers,
lizards,
you know,
that's where you lost me.
You lost me to transform it.
I'm sorry.
I've got that fucking goofy ass robots attorney.
The cars fuck off.
So when you find like a giant rib cage of a will,
how do you know when to stop looking?
How do you know?
Like we found like five or six bones.
I think we got it all.
When the bones run out,
we stopped and then we dig underneath.
But sometimes when we dig underneath to like pop what we think is everything out
and we find more and then we have to go down and then one jacket can turn into
five.
So do you have time constraints?
Like when you press that red button and shut it down,
you could go on for years.
Yeah.
If it's big enough.
Wow.
Did you ever worry about getting me assassinated?
Like I would think these fucking assholes that build parking lot structures,
you know,
like seriously man,
they can be dicks to,
they pull you in a room with a cigar smoke asshole.
No,
they don't.
They,
we,
we closed down the site so they can't even get near us unless we let them.
Why we limited to foot traffic only and we're the first ones in,
in the last ones out during the day because we need to make sure everyone else
has gone.
So nothing happens to the cause.
We're also,
we're safeguarding whatever it is we find the most adamant than anybody's ever
gotten with you about keeping a job site open.
Um,
the other week I was a working in archeological site and a guy yelled at me
because I was trying to salvage in 1800 Sears catalog that was buried in sand.
And uh,
yeah,
he was getting kind of savage.
Wifi is,
you're stopping my guys fucking piece of trash.
I'm like,
I'm sorry man.
This is a datable catalog that has hand illustrated things in it and it's
necessary from the 18 hundreds yeah.
He couldn't see that.
That's kind of cool.
Nope.
I was getting,
I was getting in the way of his excavator.
It's like,
wow.
So I closed that part of the site,
five feet of the site for three hours and he gave me a,
you're holding up my guys.
It's trash bre.
Wow,
dude.
Chill man.
Trashed from the 18 hundreds.
It's kind of cool,
isn't it?
It's like bottles and horse shoes and be loud there on agenda.
People have their own agenda.
Everybody has their own agenda.
I've always been fascinated by the idea of a fossil because when,
when we started learning in school about the fossil record and started learning
about fossils and now you look at something and it's actually not even the bone
anymore.
It's like the minerals have replaced the bone.
Like I had a conversation with a friend of mine once about that.
He had a um,
a megalodon tooth on his desk.
Yeah,
you've got one right there.
Yeah.
I found some in la too.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And then La,
the whale side I was talking about,
we actually found meg teeth before that.
Well that's what I'm saying is like,
yeah,
when you find big sharks like that,
you can find their food.
Yeah.
But Gala Don in downtown La isn't McCollough Donna's that I say there is it
Miguel it on Megla.
Don You're in fastest is on a different syllable.
It doesn't,
same thing.
Oh,
okay.
It's like nuclear new Cuellar it know that it's new.
Clear.
It's,
that's spelled new.
Clear.
Um,
did you remember how Bush,
he's just saying,
oh,
again,
new nuclear wheeler dealer.
Yeah,
nuclear bombs.
It's like,
uh,
was it uh,
Californa when a sports tenure used to say that,
uh,
um,
the scientists,
not a politician.
Huh?
The bones.
The teeth rather when they,
you see them and they're all black.
I was trying to tell him,
I go,
that's not really the tooth.
that's sort of the minerals have kind of taken over with the tooth was you're
absolutely right.
And he was like,
no,
it's fucking tooth.
I'm like too,
it used to be a tooth,
but that's why it's black.
How many black teeth you have.
He's like,
it's just fucking old.
Like I don't think it works like that.
Mineralization.
Yeah.
It,
so all the calcium gets replaced by heavier minerals in the bone,
the tooth,
all that.
That's been a,
it's been replaced.
It's been petrified.
Just petrified wood still looks like wood waste,
you know,
instead of weighing two pounds of waste,
15 fucking rock.
It's cool looking.
Petrified wood is the weirdest shit ever.
But let me tell you,
man,
I used to be that kind of paleontologist and I started working at the tar pits
and then I went to Siberia with these woolly mammoths.
They're not petrified.
Yeah.
This is what they were saying in the press thing I found so incredibly
fascinating.
Yeah.
You're finding completely flat flash frozen animals.
There was skin hair like I played with it's lips had undigested food and it's
real clear when you say played with,
yeah.
Well what are you doing?
Front mouth.
Yes.
Um,
but it's like,
yeah,
it had the,
the whole mouth structure was still there.
The lower lip,
the root of the tongue.
The root.
Yeah.
The,
it's like the word connects the base of the tongue where it connects in the back
of the throat.
It was like still in this animal.
It was an animal.
It wasn't bones.
Yeah,
it was creepy man.
Wow.
I'd never dealt with something like that before.
How did it,
how was it so well preserved at a fall into a glacier or something?
We think the way that it was preserved,
I mean you'll,
you'll see,
you'll,
you'll see in the show,
um,
we only kind of have half of a mammoth because the top half has been exposed to
weathering and all that,
but the bottom half stayed in frozen mud and permafrost.
So it probably got trapped in either a mud bank,
a pit,
something like that,
and got stuck,
died,
got buried in snow.
The whole thing froze.
And then maybe the back end of it got eaten away.
It got scavenged.
Dogs came on and when,
hey,
look free meat,
you know,
that,
that kind of,
it's just,
it's crazy.
I did a podcast with a guy named Randall Carlson.
Have you ever heard of him?
The name sounds familiar and he's an expert in Astro,
um,
in asteroidal impacts and yeah.
Yeah,
he was,
oh.
Um,
he had one example of a wooly mammoth that died almost instantly and he believes
that the impact of some sort of a large body like killed this thing and not,
not just killed it,
but broke it's back like upon impact.
Like,
so just some massive impact like,
you know,
x amount thousands of years ago,
they think like 12 plus thousand years ago.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And he had,
uh,
he had actually had photos of it,
right.
He had photos of the,
the woolly mammoth and it's broken position and they had found it very
similarly.
It was like very well preserved and,
uh,
sort of perma frozen weird,
I would think.
Something falling from space and then falling from the sky at terminal velocity,
if it's like a big rock more than just break,
something's bad.
Well,
it depends on,
I guess how close it is to the impact.
Obviously it just fucking killed everything.
Really close to Oh,
like an it impacted nearby and flattened the forest for some reason I'm thinking
like,
you know,
and meteor comes out of the sky and hits the mammoth.
Exactly.
Well,
you know that a site in Siberia,
the tongue gust school site flattened all the trees and all flattened to
everything for like some insane amount of thousands of acres and that was a
meteor impact in the 19 early 19 hundreds,
right in 1908 or something,
something along those lines.
Um,
well he believes that,
you know,
that one big one that we found is like a pittance in comparison to some
something that hit around 12,000 years ago and they think there's pretty
significant evidence all over Asia and Europe in the form of a nano nano
diamonds nuclear blast.
Now I remember his name.
Yeah.
Um,
there is,
there's,
there's evidence of that.
Um,
he did put forth pretty solid hypothesis,
but we're starting to find out we have a,
everything didn't go extinct right at that moment though.
No,
he's saying they were about 60% of all land mammals died off in that era.
That's a large,
that's a huge chunk.
Wooly mammoths kept going for how long?
A?
They were around til about 4,000 years ago.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Woolly mammoths were living on Wrangel island in northeastern Siberia when the
pyramids were being built in Egypt.
Holy Shit.
And then we had pygmy mammoths on the,
on the channel islands.
You can cruise at channel islands outside of La.
Yeah.
Pygmy mammoths.
If you cruise up to the natural history museum at Santa Barbara.
Yeah.
They have pygmy mammoths.
They're related to another mammoth species we had in North America called the
Columbian mammoth.
Wow.
Yeah.
So when were they there?
How Long Risa?
Um,
I think they went extinct about,
uh,
not for,
for some reason,
like six to 8,000 years ago.
Is this stick in my head?
Yeah.
We had,
um,
11,000,
500 years ago we still had saber tooth cats roaming la.
Yeah.
Easy off man.
Saber tooth cat.
A weird fucking animal.
Like what made that animal grow?
These huge fangs like that,
that was just in order to sink into the next of its victims.
Right.
I mean that was an entirely,
it's for,
yeah.
You're basically knives.
Yeah.
Quick,
quick,
quick and easy death.
And they say that like Saber tooth cats even,
you know,
big cats are alive today.
There's their teeth can actually sense like where the juggler is,
their teeth can like as they sync it and they can feel heartbeats through their
teeth.
You can too.
You can bite your bite,
your risks.
It's not going to do that.
I know,
but I'm just saying have somebody bite arrest,
not me.
Um,
and you can actually,
you can feel the pulsation cause in your mouth and the sensitivity of your
teeth.
Yeah.
I,
and you,
you know how your teeth hurt when you're eating something cold or drink
something.
You've got nerve endings in it.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
It makes it just,
there's may have a larger nerve ending that I'm not quite sure on cat a cat two
fanatic me,
but they may have just a larger nerve ending that allows them to feel,
uh,
easier.
Did.
So did you guys stumble upon and he,
Saber tooth cats?
Uh,
not in Siberia.
No.
And when you were doing like job sites in la?
I used to go down,
used to be the assistant lab supervisor at the,
at the La Brea tar pits.
I ran it all cats all the time.
I even dropped a skull of one on the floor accidentally.
Oh No.
When I was cleaning it shattered.
Yeah.
I put it back together kind of with glue.
Just see how long that took.
About six months.
Fuck yeah.
One slips.
Six months of work.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Ever talked to a paleontologist and they say they've never broken,
damaged or otherwise,
like impacted a bone.
They're lying.
Those motherfuckers.
Yeah,
we've all done it.
It happens.
And it's like,
imagine,
you know,
it happens man.
Shit all the time.
I mean,
I almost fell down an ice cliff in Siberia and uh,
my friend got stuck,
uh,
repelling down one and stuck.
Yeah.
You'll see.
For how long?
Um,
he wasn't stuck that long,
probably about 10 minutes.
But,
uh,
um,
so in the show you'll see Tim king,
he's a like my cohost,
like code venture or buddy.
Um,
we have to get down this ice cliff and,
and it's a huge ice cliff.
It's not like,
you know,
oh,
we're kind of going down from like the top of,
you know,
the top of Pierce college down to the street.
Know this is a mountain of ice that were repelling down to fuck ice cliffs.
That's all I have to say.
And Yeah,
the bank started eroding away and his rope jammed and he's dangling there and
freaking out and panicking and I'm like down at the bottom looking up going,
why isn't he coming down?
I'm trying to get them on radio and no one's,
yeah,
he got stuck.
We,
we both went into ice ice caves.
He got lost.
Oh No.
Light went out and he's got turned around and these caves were like minus 10
degrees.
He doesn't have a backup light.
No.
What kind of Shit is that?
I don't,
I dunno.
I do not have a backup plan.
I figured when you go a nice cave does a few things you want to bring.
One of them was a fucking backup light you think I need.
We,
we were with a whole film crew,
but for,
you know,
for narrative sake we,
it was,
it was our expedition.
He was getting me into Siberia and I was going to do biopsies and discover
mammoths and things like that.
So like going into an ice cave you think,
oh no,
I've got this great flashlight.
It's in a zip lock bag.
It's this big bank of LEDs.
I've got a little glow thing.
I've got a camera that can see in the dark and,
but no light goes out and you kind of panic a little,
a little.
Yeah.
So you guys are there.
You're uncovering how many of these mammos or uncovering that are in such great
condition?
Well,
we only got access to one unfortunately.
Um,
but finding a mammoth carcass is actually pretty rare.
You can find like a chunk of a mammoth that may have some hair or tissue,
like just falling out of a wall or something like that.
More often than not,
you find bones finding an intact or even mostly intact carcass.
A whole body is a really rare event and we were lucky enough to just to get
access to one of the newest ones because we kept striking out.
We're like,
oh,
we're going to go here and look for one.
It's like,
nope,
didn't find it.
Oh well there may be another one here.
These tusk hunters,
these guys that cut into the mountain justifying wooly mammoth tusks and sell
them because elephant ivory is illegal.
Mammoth ivory is not because the animal's already dead.
Uh,
I see these guys mammoth.
Ivory is beautiful too.
It's got a weird sort of a tan quality to it.
Yeah.
Tan kind of like kind of almost chocolaty in some places.
It's really pretty.
People use it for things,
right?
For artwork and stuff.
Yup.
Artwork,
they carve it.
So a single tusk say you have a 100 pound tusk that is perfect quality.
It's just like they pulled it out of an ice cliff,
that thing uncut will be 40,
$50,000.
Whoa.
Yeah.
There was an episode on a life below zero where they were looking for mammoth
Tusk.
If they were looking for him in the side of a mountain or a hillside in Alaska.
They that common.
Yeah,
they're pretty common enough that there's an actual commodity and an and an
entire,
uh,
there's an entire economy based on it now.
But if you find the Tusk,
it doesn't necessarily mean you'll find the body,
cause a lot of the times the body is rotting away.
Right.
Or,
and unfortunately in our case,
if they find the Tusk,
they don't care about the body.
All they want is the task.
When you think and he being a paleontologist and you think about the fossil
record,
how many holes are there in it from animals that just simply did not get
fossilized?
Oh,
we've got caps all over it.
But,
um,
like,
like trying,
I mean we've got 300,
400,
500 million year old like bacterial fossils and then we have stuff that died
last week.
I mean we have on a long enough timeline,
we have her think,
but there are spaces cause nothing,
not everything fossilizes or blade for every discovery like that hobbit man they
found and as Lori ansys dance 10 years ago already,
it's so weird.
I was just reading that on Twitter this morning,
like in the car here.
I'm like,
that's right.
It's been 10 years since the weird hobbit people,
there's still some people that try to dispute that,
but apparently they had been discredited.
The,
that was,
there was a guy who was trying to say that they were actually some form of down
syndrome children and that would,
that's what accounted for the deviation.
But the,
it seems like the consensus is no,
you're dealing with a totally different species.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not that up on my,
uh,
on my Paleo Anthro,
it's like I'm,
I'm a kind of a hardcore paleontologist.
We don't dig.
People um,
are kind of like loners and like dead animals more than what it gets.
Found a person.
I would freak out and call my boss.
Oh,
you back up.
Nope.
I don't know if you found like a heavy brow neanderthal looking motherfucker in
there,
you know,
that would,
will,
that would rewrite,
write history and that would be cool to be part of it.
But I'm actually not legally allowed to cause I'm a paleontologist,
not an archeologist.
If I come across human remains,
I stopped the entire project,
I call the coroner and my boss and then like a certified archeologist comes out.
It's very being an archeologist and dealing with people and tribal remains and
all that in California.
Very,
very specific.
And I know in Mexico City they're constantly like digging for an apartment
building or something like that and they find like some huge pyramid structure
that's been covered in dirt for thousands of years that nobody knew existed.
My Co host Tim,
he's a Mezo American archeologists.
That's his deal.
Um,
I dunno if he's on that,
on that project.
He's a teacher up north in north in nor cal.
But it's,
yeah,
that's his thing.
So yeah,
I wish I knew more about the floor.
Ansys,
uh,
think,
because stuff like that's fascinating.
Where did we come from?
And that's another one that was only,
I believe 14,000 years ago.
It was alive,
right?
The,
the floor answers flurry answers.
I,
yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
I think it was somewhere,
it was,
it was recently enough that it was like one of those whoa moments.
Like,
Whoa,
right.
There's a little person run around 14,000 years ago.
Right.
Three foot tall humans that were kind of chimp like,
but not really.
And they walked like people did.
Right.
That's a mind fuck man.
And then you've got like Australopithecus it's four and a half million years old
or pivot gets,
it's like 4.4,
whatever the,
whatever the current thing is.
Yeah.
And uh,
but you're right,
we do have gaps all over the place and occasionally they fill them and
occasionally we fill them.
Like there's,
we have a 55 million year old timeline just of horse evolution alone from when
they used to be dog sized.
Tiny little like horse,
like animals with multiple toes on their,
on their,
on their feet,
all the way up to your modern horse.
Uh,
that's like huge single hook.
We have every transitional stage for 55 million years,
including those Budweiser horses.
Yeah.
Including the Clydesdales.
What happened with them?
How did they grow here on their feet?
Is that some asshole decided to grow like a poodle?
Yeah,
it's just a,
when you get into things like that,
like horse breeds,
cap reads,
dog breeds and all that,
that's all human intervention.
That's all artificial selection.
Um,
that's,
hey,
I like that horse because it's bigger.
It can carry more and it kind of looks more noble.
So I'm going to breed that with the biggest female I have and then take their
kids and breed them with a second biggest and you just start,
you know,
you just start building this genetic pyramid of things that you like and you're,
you're naturally selecting the traits you want an artificial or artificially
selecting the traits you want and getting rid of the ones you don't.
You don't like that color.
I am only going to breed white horses.
When you first started studying paleontology and you,
you got into this subject,
this subject of animals being someone that actually actively changing the way an
animal,
that's got to be a very bizarre thing to try to conceptualize that someone took
like say like a wolf and turned it into a Chihuahua like that.
That is really the,
that's where they came from.
Right?
Yeah.
And this is only recently that discovered,
that's like the last 50,000 years,
God,
yeah,
but it's only been recently proven that they all came from wolves,
correct?
Oh yeah.
Genetically,
yeah.
Cause you can,
you can take a wolf and um,
they're so wolves and dogs,
common ancestor.
Um,
but then woves what more than likely happened was wolves have a,
you had kind of like this,
this protocol wolf.
Um,
it was just canus Lupus.
It was your normal everyday wolf,
but you have a group of them that we see.
We didn't domesticate wolves,
wolves domesticated us.
They came in closer for fire and for,
for warmth,
for food,
for protection.
So if you kind of think about it,
we were like giving scraps to these dogs and getting them to come out to come
closer.
But they're like,
hey,
I'm going to hang out with these people because they have a fire,
I have food and I can bark and let them know when things are coming.
So if you think about it,
they actually domesticate it.
US was sort of a joint effort.
No,
maybe.
I occasionally like to knock humans down to come down.
And you seem to legs err on the side of the animals.
Again,
don't dig people.
Um,
so say you have a one like small neighboring city has a big,
a really big,
big bad wolf and you have the second biggest.
So they mate and then the year those puppies are bigger.
And then,
oh well we don't want them as furry.
So only keep,
uh,
only keep the shorter coat puppies and then breed them.
And then,
yeah.
And then all of a sudden you're like,
oh,
I need really big dogs.
I don't know.
I want a small dog that I can carry around because it's fashionable.
Yeah.
It's weird,
man.
Even all our food,
like do you think a banana,
you know your normal everyday,
you know cool organic banana that you get that's not,
that's not a banana of bananas,
this weird green thing with seeds in it.
Yeah,
it's,
yeah.
We've been doing it ever since.
We stopped being nomadic and stop the hunter gatherer lifestyle and started
planting.
We've been changing our own everything.
Yeah.
That's why people when they get angry about GMO foods like,
well,
every roof need as it is modified.
Yeah.
I was like,
do you mean lab GMO?
Do you mean like gene spliced?
Right.
I mean what I,
what I call hip generic or hippy engineering,
farming engineering.
It's like I'm going to make a honey crisp apple by grafting one brand of an
apple or one breed of an apple.
Do another one that's GMO.
It's like we need to be very brief segue.
We need to be very clear on our labeling was a grown in a lab.
Does it have fruit fly DNA in it?
It's like does it glow in the dark?
No.
Okay.
It's still GMO,
but it's not like some creepy,
you know,
Oh,
I'm mixing chemicals,
you know,
God,
Apple.
Well people just,
they love to throw that around like organic,
you know?
It's like I don't eat organic.
Like,
okay,
what do you,
what the fuck are you telling me?
Define organic.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
Do you tell what that means?
Are you just saying a word that you think makes you look like a better person?
Right,
right.
It's like,
oh,
gluten.
It's like,
do you know what gluten is?
do you know,
it's like,
do you really know what free range means or grass,
fresh grass fed nor hormone,
a no hormone.
Uh,
my girlfriend,
she's,
you know,
very,
healthy eating,
very fit and a is getting me on the kick too and like teaches me this stuff like
taught me how to read a label on food and I'm like,
oh,
holy crap.
Okay,
that's cool.
Yeah,
it's,
it's good stuff.
When you actually,
when you take time to do the research things,
you know,
things just kind of pop out and it's,
it's kind of Nice that way when you have,
because we have the internet and all that.
It's easy.
It's easy to do research,
but it's also very easy to get thrown a stray with like,
you know,
I usually only read things@endinlike.edu.org.
See I'm the opposite.
I go right to the creationist forum.
I want to know how those motherfuckers is thinking.
I know how they think.
That's,
have you seen my Twitter feed that nine times out of 10 all I'm doing is
debating,
debating evolution with grease.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh,
I think I need to link your Twitter.
What's your Twitter at?
Tattoos and bones.
Really?
Yup.
Tweeting you like the last two days.
Wow.
Welcome to the club.
A lot of fucking people.
It's a lot of humans.
Are there stories that twos and bones?
Yeah.
Okay.
A N,
d bones,
one word d.
Yeah.
All right.
But yeah,
and like people are,
I get that a lot because I go to Siberia.
I,
you know,
with mammoth on
earth and I dig up a woolly mammoth carcass and I'm telling people about it.
And like occasionally I'll throw like a picture up on Twitter cause we filmed it
last year and it's just debuting on Sunday.
And then people are like,
oh well look,
you found,
you found that animal,
it's frozen.
It's proof that the world is only 6,000 years old.
I'm like,
Oh Tony,
ah,
yeah,
there's the best.
Or there's gaps in the fossil record and you know,
things like that.
And it's just like,
please just do your research.
Maybe you just need to talk to Kirk Cameron.
You know,
you're talking to a lot of shit,
but you don't really know until you sit down with Kirk Cameron.
Have you ever seen his buddy that shows that banana is proof of evolution?
That would be ray comfort.
Yes.
This dumb fuck.
Who doesn't even understand that we changed the way bananas look like he calls a
banana and atheist's nightmare.
If you've seen that video,
it's beautiful man.
Yeah,
I'm sorry.
That video is beautiful and him and Duane Gish and the Gish gallop where you're
just like throwing a word salad at somebody.
It's like,
oh,
well evolution isn't true because it's like to shut up.
They're all just gay.
That's what it is.
That's,
that's fine.
Bracing.
Oh,
it's great.
Nothing wrong with being gay,
but I really believe that that's what's going on with most of those guys.
They're the reason why there's so hog.
Wild for Jesus.
Like Kirk Cameron,
that's a gay man.
I'm not a gay man,
but I'm pretty good spot and some things in this life.
I know what a gay man it looks like.
I don't know it all game.
I looked like I'd been fooled before,
but you know what I'm saying?
It's like you put a fucking lizard outfit on dog.
I'm going to go,
Ooh,
something's up with that lizard.
What does this,
that's him with the banana.
Oh yeah,
that's there it is.
Yeah,
peeling it.
Oh Wow.
Man.
Goof bag.
It doesn't he,
but he never even bothered doing the work to understand that.
We used to have different looking fucking bananas within the,
within the written human record.
I got him that long ago.
Stupid.
Yeah,
it's,
and,
and somebody bro,
I think once somebody brought him an actual,
a non,
like an original natural banana and he was like,
what's that?
It's a banana.
You dumb.
Fuck.
Sorry.
Cause he's doesn't need that part of his brain.
His jaw just for fighting off cock,
fighting off the love of the cock.
So he puts that just,
I don't have any room for that.
I can't do that kind of research,
are busy fighting off the gay.
So,
uh,
I'll just sit here with this banana and just pontificate.
I mean,
he could if that,
if that,
if as any way,
shape or form prophecies are true,
it's my thesis.
Why,
why you such a phallic symbol?
Why did he have for all the same reasons,
he doesn't understand what he's doing.
It's wrong to,
it's the transference of,
you know,
in,
into the symbol.
So it's,
it's actually giving them power.
It makes them feel comfortable,
but it's such a ridiculous proposition that God made a food that we could hold
perfectly.
W what?
Tomatoes are no good.
Like why?
Why can't you mean a fucking tomatoes
pretty easily held to like,
that's really stupid.
Why isn't it tomato?
Banana shaped?
Which tomato?
That's true,
right?
Yeah.
You've got cherry tomatoes,
Sherry's hothouse grape,
you know,
all these different ones.
Because we've modified though.
We modify them.
We got involved.
That's why I really like my job.
I go way before all that ride.
I'm dealing with stuff that I can meet people.
Yeah.
At least pre people that had the knowledge to fuck with things.
You know,
they were still like wandering around going,
crap,
can we kill that big furry thing?
We don't know.
Maybe we'll just wait until one dies and then butcher it and like drive off the
smaller animals.
But it's stuff like that.
It's watching,
being able to be in an environment where this animal live.
Like I was in Siberia.
It was,
it was cold.
It was fucking crazy.
And I'm in the land of these animals,
looking out over the wastelands,
like in a train and seeing nothing but reindeer herds.
And,
and then then,
uh,
and then the net people,
the net people are reindeer herders and they were reindeer leather and they make
their sleds and they use mammoth ivory for mammoth tusks they find to make the
buckles for their reindeer sleds.
Wow.
And these are people that their culture has been doing this for 8,000 years.
So I'm walking with people who'd just direct relatives may have actually seen
mammoths.
Yeah.
And there's this,
there's this whole sequence in mammoth on earth where I'm hanging out with the
net people drinking reindeer blood to like,
you know,
to sacrifice a ranger to the ground.
So I can like find a mammoth cause mammoths to them or bad Juju,
malice or bad Juju.
Yeah.
They have this,
this really,
see,
I'm a,
I'm a scientist and uh,
it's like I'm not a theist.
I'm not an atheist.
I'm not even agnostic.
I'm just a scientist.
I need data.
So here I am with these people for a week,
then the net,
and I don't have my archaeologist,
anthropology buddy with me because he's,
he's on a different side of the planet at this point.
On the other side of Siberia is still trying to find a mammoth.
I chase a lead going out here and that's the time I really kind of needed him
cause I was completely out of my element.
I'm with these very naturalistic shamonic,
animistic people and they're like,
well,
you know,
mammoths are bad luck.
There are a sign of trouble.
And they tell me off camera that they have this three tiered world,
that they have an upper god,
the middle realm,
and then the lower God,
the upper God gifted the Nanette people,
the reindeer,
the lower God is too large and too powerful to use ranger.
So he uses Mamet's as herd animals and to pull his sled.
When a mammoth dies,
the bones fall into the middle world.
If the net people find them,
they have to sacrifice one of their reindeer back Wa.
Yeah.
So here I am surrounded by all these just very awesome,
caring,
Hardy,
native people.
And then they're,
well,
you know,
we're going to have to sacrifice a reindeer in order for you to find a mammoth
because if you find one,
pull any bones out,
we have to,
you know,
so do you have to compensate them for their Caribou when that happens?
No,
no,
they,
they did it.
They were very welcoming.
V Like I'm hanging out in their tent.
But like if you find a mammoth and then they have to sacrifice one of their
reindeer or Caribou.
Oh they killed,
they killed the Caribou.
Do for that.
But do you eat it or the they do they have to sacrifice that?
I have to leave it in the ground.
Like,
no,
they ain't.
They ate it,
but it doesn't go to waste.
It doesn't go to waste.
But then they pass around the cup of blood and they make everybody drink.
Oh,
including me.
What does that taste like?
Like,
like he get punched in the mouth and you know,
you're swallowing blood.
It's just,
it's blood.
But the fact that I'm watching the animal get butchered in front of me and it's
not there.
This wouldn't be some like modern weird ritualistic thing with like people
wearing like nitro gloves and it's very clean.
No that it's just like,
nope.
Slippy animal open.
Go throw the organs over there and then take this metal Coffee Cup with like
blue and pink daisy.
Print on it,
dip it into the chest cavity.
Whoa.
And pass it around.
Holla.
It's still steaming.
I mean the animal had just died 45 seconds ago.
Did you touch if you've ever touched the inside of one of those animals?
Like right after they die?
Yeah.
They're so warm.
The blood was steaming like I'm holding this like Coffee Cup,
steaming full of blood and I'm just like,
and I had a head cold at the time.
I'm just like,
oh well if will cure the common cold,
why not?
And I just chug it.
Do anything to,
uh,
no.
It kind of,
it felt like I was sucking on a whole bunch of like copper pennies.
What if you got a raging hard on?
Would you,
would you immediately like call your friends to go listen?
Um,
I think I'm onto something.
Or would you keep it to yourself?
Hmm.
I might keep it to myself.
Really?
How dare you?
You're a scientist.
Well you owe the world.
No,
I have to test it first.
Okay.
So you just keep your all,
all trailers just wandering around Russia with heart arms all the time.
Like what's he doing next?
Stop St Petersburg.
Come here.
I'm not sure.
Oh Wow.
Well not convince.
Give me another cow.
I was totally doing like the bill Hicks goat boy voice there for a moment.
It's like very similar.
Yeah,
I mammoth boy
the sound.
So when you're finding these animals,
uh,
you,
you said there were some that were existed,
existed 4,000 plus years ago.
What,
how old are the ones that you've find,
like when you found this one that is,
it's essentially like you're finding the actual body of this thing that you feel
the tissue and the hairs on it.
How old?
How old was that animal?
What about 40,000 years old.
Oh yeah.
So before humans had ever stepped foot on [inaudible] North America,
you know,
uh,
10,000 years after native aboriginal people came to a,
came to Australia.
Uh,
like we're,
it's like that's a stupid long amount of time.
We can't really get that into our brain,
can we?
No,
no.
The,
even,
even as somebody that works in what we call deep time,
like I'm,
I'm working a site right now that can be,
you know,
30,
40,000 years old,
but I just came from a site that was seven,
8 million years old,
million millions of your continence.
We're in different places.
Yeah.
That's,
it's like there was a land bridge between Asia and Alaska,
the Bering Sea Landbridge that these mammoths cruised over 40,000 years ago.
Ice was different 65 million years ago.
India wasn't part of Asia.
It hit it causing a bunch of volcanoes and a comet came in and asteroid and hit
South American wiped out the dinosaurs.
Like stuffs in different places,
man.
Yeah.
It's like,
like the rocks you hold depending on where you are.
Some of them are four and 5 billion years old.
They're as old as the earth itself.
They reformed when the solar system was forming.
It's kind of messed up to think about.
It's almost impossible.
Yeah.
As like a point of reference and your little pea brain,
the monkey brains.
I is like,
you think,
trying to think of what absolute zero is,
you know,
it's like what true nothingness.
The,
the concept of zero is very difficult because everyone's like,
oh,
you know,
I took the coffee Coffee Cup of whey,
I have zero cough,
but think about that.
Think about zero Coffee Cup.
There's zero,
there's none.
It's like trying to remove an entirety of something that is nothingness.
Then go beyond that.
Well,
I was listening to a lecture on the Big Bang where it was explaining the concept
of a pre big man universe,
which apparently they believe only existed for the amount of time that it takes
light to get like across a photon,
like the or the or across an Adam,
like,
like literally like in almost a measurably short amount of time where there was
no physics.
Yeah,
it was just,
it was a singularity.
It's just like,
yeah.
And this one,
this guy was trying to explain this.
I rewound it and played it back and forth like fucking four times in a row.
And I'm like,
Oh,
I'm too stupid.
I'm to sticking with the,
get that in.
Like I'm trying to conceptualize the idea of this.
And then I'm like,
okay,
well what happened before that?
No nose?
No,
no one knows.
I mean,
even,
uh,
and that's,
that's a thing working,
working in a hard physical science like I do,
we have radiometric dating,
we have geology,
we have biology,
we have all this stuff that tells us how old this mammoth is,
what it did,
what it's related to.
We can do gene DNA mapping and all of that.
We can see the evolutionary paths of these animals.
But then you get into,
well,
how did life on Earth Start Abby?
Genesis,
you know,
it's like,
Whoa,
okay.
Bacteria and RNA and lightening strikes and where you mean Jesus?
Um,
do you mean Jesus?
Jesus came after,
um,
it was always here since he's like,
I'm some plan.
It's part of the Lord's plan.
I would have to see empirical data on that.
Oh Wow.
So when you're finding these,
when you're finding these woolly mammoths,
is this just luck or disseminate,
alert you to the fact that they found one and then you go,
we had to use a kind of,
kind of the scary bit,
which is the Tusk hunters themselves.
So,
uh,
so tusk hunting is legal kind of,
so there's x amount of permits that are released by the Russian government for
people to go and look for tasks.
One guy that we ran into,
his name's Igor of of course,
course there were always named Igor.
Cool.
Oh Man.
Right.
Um,
and he was a cold.
He was cold.
He was like the river baron.
He had the biggest boat,
the fastest boat,
and the biggest gun on the entire Yana River.
So the biggest gun?
Yeah.
It's like a 50 caliber,
like a Barretts sniper rifle.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Or it's fuck was he shooting Soviet version of it?
Which I think is the dragon off.
Um,
uh,
but he's like,
he's the boss of that area.
He has a permit,
but there are other people in the area that don't have a tusk permit that try
and go and poach tusks because they can sell them on the black market.
It's not really more like the gray market.
You have to have a permit to get a test.
So if you're a guy and you live in Siberia and you're in your backyard and
you're digging a hole and you find a Tusk,
you can't just take that Tusk.
Nope.
Ha.
Now there's no such thing as land and mineral rights there.
Oh look,
10 or anything.
So what do you do the,
you have to like pretend,
oh,
just thinking about maybe getting a tuck license,
you know,
whatever.
You know,
you pretend you don't have $100,000 worth of Shit,
right?
Burn.
You find somebody that does have a permit or you sell it on the black market.
But these people,
since they go out wit right,
when the snow starts to melt,
right?
When the permafrost starts to get a start to get weaker,
they go in and they drill in and dig into these cliff sides.
They know where all of the big fines are first.
So,
uh,
Tim and I had to get in well with this kind of weird gray hat,
semi mob scene of Tusk hunters and here's like two American dudes walking in,
you know,
one's dressed as Indiana Jones was ones dressed as a biker coming in and going,
hey,
do you know where any mammoths are?
And they're looking at us like,
yeah,
you're wealthy American dude.
Um,
we don't really want to tell you because you're going to take the tusks away and
this is our entire commodity.
So we had to really be nice to them and really be very,
very differing because we heard a few times that some of these tusk bosses,
the big guys,
kind of like Igor,
there was a group that went in to poach him.
One got sent home in a box.
They killed him.
Yeah,
because he was poaching.
Yeah.
Well in likes one dude's area.
So we're,
we're dealing with serious people.
Like we're walking through parts of,
you know,
Nowheresville,
northeastern Siberia past,
you know,
cars that like with bullet holes in them.
And this is like,
it's not the wild west,
it's the wild east.
It's laws don't really apply in some of the places we were in Wa so it's just a
completely different animal.
Oh yeah.
It's,
it was something I'd never,
I was not prepared for.
So how long does the politics of like getting in with these people,
how long does that take for them to trust you to the point where they're going
to lead you to the style?
Well,
we,
we would talk,
uh,
you know,
we would have people talk on our behalf for a couple days and then we would go
meet them.
We kind of try and butter them up and vodka or some shit.
Yeah,
no,
no better.
We brought them like Jamison,
uh,
things like that.
Don't say better to them.
Uh,
no,
but the than vodka,
no man,
you break out,
break out a bottle of Jameson private reserve.
They go nuts.
Really?
They love Jamison's.
Yeah.
What about Jack Daniels?
What about a good goddamn American beverage?
No,
we don't.
we tried man.
Makers,
makers would have been good.
I didn't have,
there wasn't any at the duty free shop cause we,
I flew from La to London to Moscow and that was,
so I flew from La to London,
spent 19 hours in London gearing up and hit a duty free shop at Heathrow before
we got to Moscow.
So then we flew to Moscow,
then we flew something like across I think 10 times zones to this tiny little
town called Yakutsk.
And once you're there,
all bets are off because yeah,
trying to find anything there that remotely resembles something American is,
I was not ready for this.
Wow.
It was,
it was really weird man.
So do you speak Russian or read Russian?
No,
I kind of started a,
kind of started faking it to the point I was there for six weeks.
It got to the point where,
you know,
uh,
like,
thank you.
[inaudible]
you know,
stuff like that just kind of started to happen.
I did,
however,
go on an adventure by myself,
no production assistants,
no director,
nothing,
trying to track down a pharmacy because I had like an ear infection.
And I'm like,
okay,
so I'm on Google trying to learn the words and then try and it's like uptake
ethica and people are like,
oh Duh,
Duh Dude,
I don't understand Russian.
So I'm like in a weird combination of Google,
translate maps on,
on my phone and then starting to recognize how the letters work.
I found a pharmacy,
I was proud of myself.
How long did that take?
About 45 minutes.
And it was right around the corner from the hotel.
So I went like four different opposite directions.
And then,
yeah.
And then you have to find ear infection medication.
Try asking someone that doesn't speak English for hydrogen peroxide.
What does it look like in Russian too?
They have that wacky language yet cyrillic,
it's all like,
like upside down cues and all week.
So it,
it's,
it was,
it was an adventure man.
It was absolutely an adventure.
I in,
some of them I wish were in the show,
but the,
the stuff that's in the show,
it's going to blow your mind.
We're in ice caves were,
were climbing down.
Cliffs were touching,
physically touching the skin of a wooly mammoth that that's like 40,000 years
old.
I'm like,
I'm showing the trunk the task,
I'm doing a full biological study on this thing with tissue and blood and the
environment that you're doing this in a,
how is it outside,
outside of permafrost cave.
In a truck.
Yeah.
And so do you cover this thing when you find it,
do you like how do you try it?
You attempt to mitigate the damage that the son and the one woman,
the one we finally got our hands on was discovered a few months before and it
was secret hid away in this weird,
uh,
it was like a permafrost fish locker.
It's this natural cave that they store their food in.
So were we were the first Westerners to see this thing cause it like,
it kind of made a news,
uh,
news,
splash.
It was like the bleeding mammoth and everyone's like,
oh cool.
You know,
there's a woolly mammoth,
it's leaking blood.
And I'm like,
I need,
if,
if we're in Siberia,
I need to see this mammoth because this is like the newest and baddest mammoth.
I've got to see this thing.
So we go and we track it down and we go into this,
this permafrost fish locker and,
and you'll see in the show,
we were kind of like walking along and then we turn and there's this mammoth
shape snowball.
It's covered in snow and ice,
but we're the first,
the,
again,
the first Westerners because this had been found by a small group of people in
this tiny little fishing village called [inaudible].
No one had seen it yet.
So it takes you,
they find it and they find that they store it and hide it away.
And then how does the word finally get to the paleontologist in Los Angeles?
Um,
through,
funny enough,
through Google and Twitter and things like that,
there's this big,
if you search back to last May know is,
may have,
uh,
may of 2012,
no,
it was may of 2013.
Um,
uh,
there was the bleeding mammoth that was found.
It's the Lia Kowski mammoth.
The,
the Russians,
uh,
that founded,
one of them is a paleontologist for the northeastern federal university.
There it is.
Yeah.
Check it out.
That's the,
that's the goal.
That's the bleeding mammoth.
That was found way back then.
And what that looks like a rock.
Right?
But you're actually looking at the front,
uh,
left leg and uh,
so it's totally frozen.
Uh,
it's like this rock,
rock hard permafrost ball at this point.
So you've got the front left leg and you've got the Scapula,
the uh,
so the very up underneath the discovery news logo there.
That's the,
uh,
that's where the mouth is.
Whoa.
But it's all,
you know,
it's completely frozen and this little thing and bleeding in what way is that?
They found this goo leaking out of it or leaking out near it and it,
it took the world by storm briefly and we're like,
okay,
this is weird.
I'm going to Siberia.
I got to check this man without,
it's got to be there.
It didn't just like show up.
People go,
hey look,
we've got liquid blood.
Haha,
we've got this mammoth.
And then they make it disappear.
It's like,
screw that man.
I need to find this mammoth.
If I'm kind of striking out finding other Mamet's,
I've got to at least get my hands on one.
And we managed to track that mammoth down and I brought on a whole slew of Jay,
just this portable lab of an endoscope,
a biological microscope.
I was going to see if it has blood,
look at the trunk tissue,
look at all this stuff and like start this mini autopsy on a mammoth body.
Wow.
It was a trip.
I mean you'll,
you'll see it's,
it's really intense man.
What's your feeling on these people that want to clone something like this?
Because this is,
yeah,
this is a real issue that we're heading into in 2014 where we actually have the
capability of doing something like this where they can take some DNA from some
sort of a living dinosaur or living,
um,
elephant rather,
and figure out a way to create a mammoth people.
Yeah.
People have been asking me this,
um,
uh,
a lot,
recently,
especially since we're,
you know,
doing all the press for mammoth on earth here.
They keep saying it's like,
oh,
it's like clone mammoths,
clone mammoth.
I,
I don't believe,
yes,
we can probably do it.
It'll probably take longer than we think.
Maybe like 50,
60 years.
It's not like a five from now.
From now.
Yeah.
The way as technology advances,
I mean there was a Korean geneticists team,
uh,
on site while we were filming in case,
because they were also looking after looking for that mammoth.
And I actually became really good friends with a couple of them and we were
talking at length in there.
It's like,
yeah,
it's like maybe 50,
60 years away from right now.
But the problem is,
at least in my personal and mildly,
slightly professional view,
it's unethical.
Hmm.
Why bring back an animal just to kill it?
Why would you kill it?
It would eventually die.
It's,
it's,
uh,
the,
it,
it would not have a mammoth life.
The mammoth step,
the environment that it would lived in is extinct.
All other members of its species and genus for that matter are extinct.
You could say that it was naturally selected to be,
to be extinct.
It was gone.
It didn't survive be it get hunted by humans or whatever the prevailing theory
is right now.
That animal is no longer here.
If we bring back one solitary individual,
how lonely,
how has that ethical,
we can figure out social aspects of of mammoths by watching their direct
cousins.
The elephant you,
you put a rug on an elephant.
There you go.
There's your woolly mammoth.
Couldn't we have like an island called luck Paleolithic Park and have like a
bunch of clone mammoths wander around and we have a,
a nice place where you could take your family.
Look Connie,
there's the mammoth.
Let me tell you man.
I mean I've been,
I've helped a design like use paleontology and design like life size puppets,
saber tooth cats and,
and stuff like that.
Yeah,
I would love to see a dinosaur or a mammoth or a saber tooth cat or
archaeopteryx,
you know,
some amazing,
awesome fossil.
But these things are gone and it's more than just that the animal is no longer
living in the environment it lived in is no longer there.
We're not exactly sure what it ate.
If we can pin down the exact grasses and everything that a woolly mammoth eight.
What if they're extinct in the wild now we can't feed it what it would normally
eat.
Many kid eat fucking TV dinners.
Who gives a shit?
If I could look at them and I'm saying you can,
they're frozen frozen carcasses that pop out of the ice.
Go check them out man.
I completely see your point.
I totally understand.
I'm only fucking around but no worries.
But the reality is if someone cloned a fucking dinosaur,
I'm there.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
I bells on shit.
I want to be that,
that cliche moment of Dr. Grant,
Jurassic Park,
like falling out of the jeep and like knocking his sunglasses off and going
like,
holy crap,
that's a Fracchia soar.
I want to see the t rex steal the goat from the road.
Right,
right.
I'm going to be there.
I want it.
Chokes that thing down.
Uh,
just have a bunch of marines standing by with giant guns.
Like move you make one bad move,
but it's over dinosaur fuck face.
I get it.
The idea of that would be awesome.
I mean,
the idea of it,
when it comes to a t rex,
you're dealing with a 40 foot long animal that had 10,000 plus pounds of force
per byte and Jesus rode it around 6,000 years ago.
6,000 years ago.
It was,
I think it was,
yeah,
6,000 years ago with Thursday.
Funny,
I think it was like Thursday,
October 23rd [inaudible] 66,000 years ago.
It's like,
it's the anniversary of Jesus riding the velociraptor in Nevada from Galilee
right now.
It seems inevitable though that some,
someone's going to do something along these lines.
Like I agree with you that it's probably not ethical to Colona mammoth,
but when you start collecting things like blood,
you have like,
like real genetic tissue.
Uh,
if there was any blood left,
we would,
there wasn't any blood.
Now,
the problem with the problem with,
uh,
the same thing that would,
if that happens to a mammoth,
it's the same thing.
If I put like,
you know,
myself and permafrost or you,
anybody,
it doesn't matter how fit you are,
how have,
uh,
adapted to the environment you are,
anything like that.
When a mammal self freezes,
all the liquid inside freezes and the,
uh,
the ice crystals form and shatter the cell wall leaking out all of the genetic
material into this soup.
Uh,
so you need an intact cell with a complete nucleus in order to even begin
thinking about cloning.
Really?
Yeah.
That's fascinating.
So you,
we have the woolly mammoth genome,
but we don't have the genetic information from a single individual to actually
begin cloning.
Oh.
So that's why it would be like 40 or 50 years now acknowledged.
He's just not quite at that level yet.
And we don't have the evidence yet.
We don't have the physical requirement of mammoth DNA.
So when you're finding this Goo,
what exactly is it?
This is an exploded cell.
It's exploded cells.
Um,
it's like,
uh,
blood like hemoglobin stained tissue and melted.
Um,
it's this,
the same thing that would happen if you'd like,
put a stake in a deep freezer for a year.
And then take it out and let it sit on your counter for overnight.
It just turns into this just cellular goo.
It's a stake in a deep freezer turned in Google.
What do you mean?
Yeah,
if you let it.
So after you thought out,
it just starts to decompose after.
How long are you talking about?
Usually like a couple of days and started,
you know,
just leave it out at room temperature.
It's kind of bad.
But that's different than a regular piece of meat that you leave out in room
temperature.
No,
no.
Well yeah,
actually it is once,
once the cells,
once they get cold enough to burst the,
they're still be cohesion.
You'll still have like muscle tissue,
but it'll start to leak out and be kind of gross.
And it kind of starts us.
We'll,
at least when it comes to the man at the search to smell like a barnyard or
really bad one because after all the ice,
so we're,
we're checking it every,
uh,
every couple minutes,
every hour or so with a thermal scanner.
And at first it was all nice and solid and hard.
And we drilled a couple holes through the tissue when it was hard in order to
take core samples and look at muscle tissue and then we noticed this Goo,
which is a combination of seller material and water,
you know,
melting ice,
mud,
what's left of blood and just grow,
starting to seep out of the holes and yeah,
it's,
it's kind of disgusting.
It's pretty wild though.
You're actually getting a liquid from this animal.
There was exists that existed 40,000 years ago.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's,
it kind of messes with your head.
Even if it was,
we filmed it last year and it's just,
it's airing on Sunday and just the about it is like,
no,
this time last year I was still recovering from like poking a mammoth.
Recovering.
Yeah,
just mentally recovering.
Oh,
I see.
Yeah.
It was just like,
was like,
no,
I didn't get some like mammoth super flu or anything like,
which would be cool.
That is something to think about,
right?
Like,
yes.
Is it possible that baby rear or some diseases could survive bacteria and
viruses and all that?
They're much hardier than a human cell is.
I know tricking,
there's some,
there's some strains of tricking gnosis that can survive a deep freeze.
They say that some strains of chicken gnosis uh,
you can get from,
uh,
something that's been frozen for like years,
so he can take a piece of meat from an animal in his trick and Gnosis and it was
a couple of years thought out and cook it.
If you don't cook it to 160 degrees,
you can get chicken houses,
which is insane.
That means those larva survived deep freeze for years.
Yeah.
What the fuck man?
It's there.
It's,
that's,
that's evolution right there.
That's like,
nope.
You know,
we're gonna,
we're gonna hang out and be hardy and just,
you know,
the,
the weaker ones die nature.
Scary dude.
Yeah.
Nature is totally scary.
That's why it's scary to clone a mammoth,
right?
Because who knows what you would,
what kind of fucking crazy new plague I think,
think uh,
what is it?
Jurassic Park to the t rex goes and destroys San Diego and then all of a sudden
we have like a rampant woolly mammoth,
like tearing apart,
you know,
downtown Seoul.
I mean,
that shit.
That shit so quick.
Yeah.
True of big 14 light that fucker up like a Christmas tree and then we'd all have
made mistakes.
I wanted to actually try piece of the meat from the mammoth.
Yeah.
They wouldn't let me.
He really wanted to eat and really wanting to try it.
Yeah.
Why would you do that?
Why not?
Because it's 40,000 years old and you could just have a sandwich instead.
I'm already,
I'm already doing the once in a lifetime thing.
Everybody has to fucking,
well,
I have to take it into my body.
Well,
I come on,
I already,
at this point it's,
I'd had,
you know,
I've been finding mammoth bones.
I've been drinking reindeer blood.
Come on after a barbarian and this point wearing like leather underwear.
Yeah.
No,
I still,
the Parka actually still smells like mammoth now that I know that you mentioned
that.
Really?
Yeah.
I wouldn't wash it either.
Why was the washing part in it?
Don't you don't want to,
it's a smells like an animal in that live 40,000 years ago.
That's pretty damn cool.
Right?
Wow.
So is this the ultimate for you to be able to find this,
this animal,
the woolly mammoth carcass?
It,
it really was.
I mean,
it was an absolute dream come true.
you'll,
you'll see in the show on the Sunday night it airs.
Yeah.
It's a,
so it errors,
it's it headlines National.
The national GGR that bad,
bad,
bad.
Um,
I can already hear it in my head.
It's like,
don't mess up the name.
It's like I'm bad at my own pres.
It airs Sunday night,
8:00 PM Eastern Pacific as it headlines,
the national geographic channels.
Day of Expedition Marathon.
It's,
yeah,
it's a two hour documentary and a,
yeah.
Nat Geo Channel.
Sunday the 26th at 8:00 PM and if you're in la though,
you can see it two days early.
Why is that?
Because I'm throwing a party at my friend's bar.
Oh,
Shit.
Up Mammoth Party and the party.
When,
what day is this?
Friday night.
Eight 30 are you going to be here fucker?
Oh really?
Bummer man.
Yeah,
I would love to come to your mammoth party.
We're going to put it up onto the,
it's my friend's Barts and east Hollywood.
It's the faculty powerful plug for the factory POW faculty.
Powerful plug for the faculty there and,
and,
and the,
the preview party east La Hollywood is Hollywood.
Is that technically like silver lake?
That's a new way of saying silver lake,
east Hollywood.
We're in this weird little,
it's,
it's this bizarre place where we're not quite Los Felis.
We're not quite silver lake and echo park and we're not quite Korea town.
You should just run out there and buy real estate for East Hollywood right now
just because the fact that you've said that,
it's kind of like this cool new spot.
People like cheese,
that's the new place.
Fucking mad scramble to buy real estate in east Hollywood.
I've been there for three years now and create a market,
but it's weirdly enough,
it's already starting to do it of course,
because it's like there's the hip,
like,
you know,
craft beer,
wine place.
So that,
that my friends got,
and then like the boutique ice cream,
the tattoo shop,
the crossfit place,
you know,
it's just like in this one corner.
I love that area.
I Love Los Felis.
I love silver leg.
I don't live there,
but my buddy Duncan does and I,
whenever I go to visit them,
we walk around his neighborhood.
I'm like,
dude,
this is the weirdest part of La.
It's like this is a Melrose in Vermont,
Melrose in Vermont.
No Rosen heliotrope right there.
Wow.
That's a great,
weird little like,
it's like boutique antique shop.
Really.
It's like three blocks down.
Somebody just got shot.
This is bizarre.
So,
uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's crazy.
Oh,
that sucks man.
That'd be Rad if you could come do my friend.
[inaudible] it does sound pretty bad ass though.
Yeah.
So airline mammoth.
And now that you've done this,
what,
what's next for you?
I mean,
this is essentially the ultimate view.
Uh,
yeah.
I,
I mean I found a woolly mammoth.
Well one,
I went to northeastern Siberia where very few American paleontologists ever go.
I'm one of the few people to actually touch and interact with a actual like
woolly mammoth carcass.
It's kind of,
it is right now.
It is the ultimate for me,
but man,
I don't know what's next and like how can I top that other than like digging out
a tyrannosaur in the middle of Montana or there is a lot of that in Montana,
right?
Yeah.
Montana is a huge,
it's a,
because there was like a,
it's called the western interior seaway.
It connected the Great Lakes and the Gulf of Mexico and that's why Kansas and
all that,
that's all good farmland.
It's because it was underwater.
So Montana,
Utah,
that they were,
they were swampy areas.
Yeah.
I've been to the area,
the bad lands in Montana and those mountains where you're walking around on
silt.
Yeah.
The mountains are covered with what was essentially the bottom of the great
western inland sea.
Yeah.
So yeah,
the Dakota's a all that they find sell shells up there.
Yeah.
Like seashells.
Which is just like,
what the fuck?
Mike,
Mike coworker at Swca Lee,
he's like a tried and true Montana paleontologist.
He's had his hand in more t rex skeletons than anybody I know.
Wow.
He's,
he's a,
he's a really cool dude.
And uh,
did they find mega dawns in Montana as well?
Oh,
I don't know.
They do in Bakersfield.
Bakersfield,
California.
Yeah.
Walk just up north.
There's actually a place called shark's tooth hill because they found,
they found meg meg teeth there.
Wow.
Yeah.
Chilay um,
there's ones that are out in the Carolinas and Georgia and Florida,
uh,
all over the place.
Yeah.
They're,
they're fantastic man.
How much does it piss you off when you see those shows where they pretend that
they have footage of a mega don those?
Have you seen that goofy shit where they actually have fake photos from like
World War II?
I purposely don't watch them because then my blood sugar goes up and I probably
end up doing a Twitter tirade and my girlfriend would get mad at me.
And why would she get mad at you for a Twitter tirade?
Oh,
there was one time I think in like two days.
I,
I did like over a thousand tweets just like debating people.
It's just because it becomes all focused.
I've,
I'm just,
you know,
my brain's kind of wired different than,
than a lot of people.
I will just focus a nitpick and just go nuts and she's just like,
you know,
you could be doing,
I,
I'm not going to scroll through hundreds of tweets.
It's like,
what's going on?
I'm like,
oh,
I,
I was making a point.
He was saying there were gaps in the fossil record and yeah.
Oh,
it was it one of those dudes who,
one of the evolutionary yeah,
yeah.
Deniers.
Yeah.
That's,
uh,
unfortunately incredibly common.
But yeah,
I've,
uh,
unfortunately credibly common in the US,
not in other places.
No.
Really?
We're one of the highest rates of evolution,
denial and science denial in the entire world.
What do you tribute that to?
Um,
corn,
GMO corn?
Is that what it is?
Months Sato it's chem trails.
It's nothing.
Not even gonna get started in on all that,
man.
I'm again,
I'm a scientist.
They need data.
Um,
I don't,
I don't know.
Maybe it's,
it's freedom.
It's actual freedom.
It's the freedom to believe.
It's the freedom to have faith.
It's,
it's great.
It's a great thing to have.
It's a great thing to question.
I don't knock that.
I don't knock religions.
I don't knock.
I've a lot of people that are religious.
I have a lot of people that are atheists,
that are all good friends of mine.
I do not in any way,
shape or form care what you believe.
Just keep it out of my science.
Don't,
don't tell me that,
you know,
300 years of geology
is wrong.
Don't tell me that.
I'm effectively lying to the public.
The public.
Do you know that the earth is 6,000 years old?
Actually.
Exactly.
Man.
They had a recent Gallup poll that was some,
something insane.
Like 46% of Americans believe that the earth is less than 10,000 years old.
Yeah.
10,000 years or last year.
Something like that.
That hurts.
Yeah.
I that that,
that directly flies into my entire way of thought,
feeling and all of that and yes,
I let it be instead of just like,
you know,
putting my blinders on and going through just like doot,
doot,
Doo Doo.
That's cool.
Yeah,
but to keep it out of my science,
I kind of feel like that's the last crazy gasp of,
uh,
this,
this sort of a science denial.
I feel like this,
what we're experiencing right now is the last crazy gasp of it.
As we,
we're,
we're in this incredible age of information,
but I believe that even what we're experiencing right now will pale in
comparison to the access to data that we'll have and just 20 or 30 years that
it'll be something symbiotics.
I'm some chip or something.
Having your brain where it'll almost be impossible to deny because we kind of
have like a symbiotic connection with technology mean you essentially everyone
feels lost without their phone.
You put on glasses,
what has glasses,
it's technology that's allowing you to see when you really can't see that
there's going to be something that's going to be better than glasses.
We do have what's called contact lenses.
Okay.
Now it's on my eyeball.
No,
he's actually in a print something in your eyeball and it's permanent and you
never have to worry about it breaking and it's a simple procedure.
Okay.
We'll do it.
Your memory sucks.
So we're going to do is we're going to give you a chip and we're going to,
all your memories would now be stored on your chip.
You'll be able to plug in and send them to your friends.
Okay.
Is it painful?
No,
no,
no.
You don't feel a thing.
Okay.
We'll do that.
And then boom,
boom,
boom.
And it's going to get to a point where there is 6,000 years old.
No,
it's not.
Fuckface come here.
Come over here.
Boom.
I'm going to show you the actual evolution of the earth itself.
You'll be able to see in the next 10 minutes how we've proven that.
I think.
I think it's the last gasp of the science denialism that we see right now.
I think it's the last gasp.
I kind of hope so,
and I think within a hundred years it's going to be over.
That'd be,
that would be rad.
Um,
that'd be really rad.
It seems like it has to be.
It,
it,
it doesn't seem like it has to be.
It needs to be.
It needs to be because that's what's holding us back as a species is it's like
personal beliefs.
I just read this fantastic article on the difference between belief where
somebody says,
I believe in,
I believe the earth is four and a half billion years old or I believe it's 6,000
years old.
One is I believe factually that the earth has four and a half billion.
It's like I believe I have faith in.
We need to figure out how to keep those both within the public
thought,
both within the idea that it's perfectly okay to have these sorts of beliefs,
but science doesn't impact religion.
We're not out to kill God or anything like that.
We're just out to ask questions or the way you said that,
it makes me think you want to kill God.
No,
I don't.
I don't care.
It's completely irreverent.
Yeah.
You cannot disprove an unprovable.
It's there.
Why?
Why even bought?
Why waste the time?
Well,
it's just folks.
I think the existential angst that comes along with being a human being,
it's very difficult to manage and there's a lot of people that look for all
sorts of tools and vehicles for distributing their,
just the anxiety of being alive and they take comfort in some strange things.
I've had these conversations with people before where they defend religion by
the fact that it gives people comfort and like,
okay,
that's all well and good man,
but you know,
whoa.
Think about how many great people have been Christian and great people have
believed in real.
That's all well and good,
but it doesn't mean anything.
The reality of what we can measure,
what we can prove,
what we can show,
what we've learned,
if that is in any way impacted by these people who believe things.
If it's in hindered,
retarded,
slowed down,
diverted in any way,
then those belief systems are fucking dangerous was they're confusing and they
get in the way of our understanding.
As much as we know now,
we know an incredible amount with still in unbelievably limited amount of
information we have in comparison to what's actually out there for us.
To discover and we have an just an a measurable amount of competing data too,
which is kind of the problem.
It's having competing data is fine.
Having data that has completely thrown together with confirmation bias and,
oh no,
it has to be this because I don't like that.
It's like,
just let the method do its job.
Let Science,
let science as a tool.
You don't win when you break a hammer,
you,
you bitch at the tool,
but it's your fault that you didn't see the crack or anything like that in it
sciences,
the tool use the tool the way it's the way it's supposed to be used.
Let it test things,
let it do that.
It's,
it doesn't mean it doesn't have any malice.
The nice thing is,
you know what?
If you're wrong,
that's rad because if you're wrong,
that means you can come up with a whole new idea of cool shit to do.
You found some new stuff.
Yeah.
You having a negative is a positive.
Having a negative result means that it's something else,
which is cool.
It's an unanswered question.
If you answer the question,
cool,
refine it,
make it better.
Again,
personal beliefs are fucking Rad,
man.
If it makes you a better person and it's another tool in your basket to use,
whether it's digging up a mammoth or finding the cure for cancer,
by all means,
please use it.
Just don't bring it into science.
Don't have confirmation bias.
Don't do you know,
oh,
we,
we can't.
Uh,
we can't believe that because of the earth is only 6,000 years old.
Why are you doing that?
Why are you going against hundreds of years of geology and science and
technology and all of this stuff that we've already unlocked?
That was the stopes.
That's the problem is planning.
Dopes.
They're something.
It's easy to be a dumb dumb.
We got a real cushy life.
It's easy to be negative and it's easy to,
yeah,
it's easy to be stupid.
Yeah.
Those are two really easy things to be.
Oh,
I'm always negative.
Oddly enough.
Yeah.
Well,
the Twitter rants thousand tweets in a day.
I want to go outside,
dude.
No,
but I'm usually outside.
That's the thing.
That's true,
right?
Work.
It's slow.
I'm waiting for the excavator,
blew a hydraulic line and I'm just like,
Doo,
Doo Doo.
Oh you motherfucker.
And then you just go off on a,
yeah.
And then,
you know,
I make my point and then they come back.
I'm like,
no,
you're not getting it.
And then I make my point again and then they come back.
I'm like,
no,
you're still not getting it.
Here's a 43 page pdf on 55 million years of horse evolution.
Oh,
it's all the same kind.
Do you,
do you think that you're being trolled ever?
Do you think people recognize that you do this?
Well,
kind of because I follow a few accounts,
uh,
that actually purposely retweet them.
They retweet the stupid on purpose,
on purpose.
Just to start.
Yeah.
If,
if man came from monkeys,
why are there still monkeys?
That's my thing.
That's why I was telling him because we didn't come from monkeys,
man,
Bro.
You don't even know.
Right,
right.
Okay.
Now you see if,
uh,
whoa,
um,
yeah.
It's like,
take that Darwin Renew retweets that question.
That's all he does.
And he gets into debates and it's like,
that's okay,
I'll follow that one says take that Darwin.
No,
that,
that's the account.
Take that Darwin.
Oh,
that's funny.
Yeah.
I need to check that out.
And then there was also like theory fail theory fail when people say evolution
is fake because it's just a theory.
Oh,
that's great.
It's like theory is the biggest thing ever.
And science heard intelligent people who are educated biologists are being
referred to as non Darwinists or they believe in a non Darwinian form of,
of evolution.
What,
what other potential forms of evolution are there or what?
Or are hypothesized the mirror that people believe?
I that I'm not that sure on to be honest.
I,
I have no,
I've never heard that a non darn when neo Darwinist on,
on,
on Darwinian,
I've never,
never heard that.
Really?
Yeah.
Maybe I'm just hanging out with idiots.
Okay.
Non Darwinian evolution.
I'll Google it.
Yeah.
It's a scholarly articles for non Darwinian evolution.
Oh Wow.
Okay.
Um,
scientific paper written by Jack Lester King Thomas H.
Duke's published in 1969 is credited along with a moot Motu.
Kimora was 1968 paper evolutionary rate of the molecular level at the molecular
level,
proposing what became known as the neutral theory of molecular evolution paper
brings together a wide variety of evidence ranging from protein sequence
comparisons to studies of the Trevor's mutated gene and ECO lie.
Trevor's mutater gene.
Cool.
Troffers two F's,
um,
uh,
analysis of the genetic blah,
blah,
blah.
Tweet me that link so I can check that later.
Yeah,
sure.
Definitely.
These other interviews that I'm doing today.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Who else are you doing today?
Um,
Marilu Henner,
Marilu Henner and she'll like a gymnast or something?
No,
the,
the actress.
Um,
she was on taxi.
Oh,
Marilu Henner all the,
the redheaded lady.
Yeah.
And she,
uh,
it's really cool.
Uh,
yeah,
she has,
she's supposed to be a genius.
I,
she,
she has a photograph,
like a bizarre,
amazing,
awesome photographic memory.
She could remember the very day,
the time,
like of 1979 it was in my living room.
It was 12:00 PM and this happened.
And Yeah.
And,
and weirdly in this big grand synthesis of the world,
she filmed a movie in my girlfriend's old home in Toronto,
like in 94 and has assigned headshot.
My girlfriend has a sign headshot from Marilu Henner,
so like,
wow.
Yeah.
And I'm going to ask her,
I'm going to like,
Hey,
do you remember like this,
this,
this house in Toronto?
She does.
And she'll probably like,
oh yeah.
And the,
it was near a thing with that and the wallpaper was this color,
which was kind of like air crew and it was just like,
whoa.
And she's a very rare example of that.
Right?
Extremely.
I actually think I got to be bugging off to get to that.
Is it,
does she have a podcast or something gets syndicated?
Radio?
I'm Marilu Henner is a syndicated radio show.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
What's it,
what's the subjects about anything she wants?
No Kid.
Yeah,
it's Mary Lou.
Uh,
yeah,
on Twitter.
It's at Mary Lou show.
Asar interviewed once and I was like,
wow.
She surprisingly intelligent.
Yeah.
And that whole photographic memory thing.
Right.
That's a bummer.
If you date her though,
you know you can't say that.
Oh,
Oh yes,
yes.
And the resident,
the,
yeah,
the relative humidity was 83% and it was okay man.
Well listen,
thank you very much for coming on here.
If you've got to go see Mary Lowe,
I totally understand.
This is amazing.
Tattoos and bones on Twitter.
You can follow him on Twitter and this Sunday.
Yeah,
this Sunday,
eight time,
8:00 PM on the National Geographic Channel.
Mammoth on earth.
Listen Dude,
I'm so happy as people like you out there doing that.
It's so cool to be able to like enjoy
the fruits of your labor and just take in this information.
Thanks knowledge and I'm looking forward to your show.
Thanks man.
Checkout museums.
Get out there.
Anyone can do my job to be honest.
No,
that's not true.
You have to.
You have to be into it.
No,
I'll take you out camping.
We'll find fossils that we find out.
Oh,
I know how that works.
No,
not like that.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
With rate with Ray,
comfort's banana.
There we go.
Trevor via ladies and gentlemen.
That's how you say it.
If you want to be cool.
Thank you brother.
I really appreciate it.
That was awesome.
This is amazing.
Yeah.